thank you for having me
um
well this talk is based on some showing
work with gabriela geronimo and juan
xavier
and
up to now my research has been mainly
focused on the development of
theoretical results and efficient
algorithms to be able to describe the
common set of zeros of a system of m
polynomials in n variables
and because of the applications
that
there's a lot of applications that have
a relatively
equations that describe them with
relatively few monomials and because we
are looking for efficient algorithms is
that there's some interest in the sparse
polynomial systems
this is these systems are systems where
the monomials that have
coefficients with that are non-zero are
fixed are preset
and to this
fixed setting of monomials that we are
going to represent by their exponents we
are going to call supports and use this
notation here a 1 2 am
my algorithms are not numerical ones
but symbolic ones this means that we're
gonna describe the variety by using
geometric resolutions parameterizations
by means of
these geometric resolutions
and in the zero-dimensional case when we
have a variety that is definable over
the rationals
if we if we have a linear form that
sends different points to different
values
then exometric resolution is going to
parameterize the variety using this
polynomial here this univariate
polynomial and
um
a set of polynomials we want to be n
that they are chosen such that if we had
the roots of q of q and we evaluate them
in this vector here we recover the
variety v
this definition can also be extended to
the equidimensional case if we have a
variety a an e-dimensional variety of
the dimension r
and for each reducible component
we have a
free maximal set of variables
such that for each irreducible
components this
condition holds then we can get again to
go to the zero differential situation by
inverting that set of
maximal free variables
the
my algorithms are also probabilistic in
the sense that they make some random
choices of interiors that if we chose
them outside the farishi class
proper set
allow us to get a correct result
and
something to be said before i start a
difference between the case the generic
square sparse case and the generic
squares dense case is that if we had
as many polynomials as variables
and with fixed degrees and every
possible monomial that can appear has
equational coefficient then the common
set of zeros is finite
but if we fix the monomials that can
appear then we can have
components of positive dimension
dimension for example with this system
here if we factor the system looking at
which of these variables can be made
zero we obtain five
irreducible components and only one of
them is a point
so we are interested
in knowing
when we're going to be able to find
components of positive dimension
in coordinate linear spaces and of which
dimension these components are going to
be
a question to ask beforehand is in
in which parameters one wants to write
the
the complexity of the algorithms
some
a combinatorial environment that is
expected to appear is the degree of a
variety somebody that i think everybody
knows but just in case
for an irreducible variety the
definition is the maximal amount of
points in the intersection of the
variety with as many hyperplanes as
the dimension
as long as this amount set of these
points are finite
and this number is achieved in
dictionary for
generic hyperplanes
and for arbitrary varieties the
definition of degree that i'm gonna be
using this lecture is the sum of all
degrees of of each and every one of the
irreducible components of the variety
so so even if there are different
dimensions
yes
okay
i'm gonna use this notation a lot
i'm gonna call this way to the variety
defined by the union of every
irreducible component of the variety
defined by a system f that has at least
one point with all non-zero coordinates
that is the same thing as the sariski
closure of the set of all serials of the
system with all non-zero coordinates
so using that
notation then for a generic system with
at most
polygenetic system either that variety
is going to be empty or
in the case when the amount of
polynomials is less or equal to the
amount of variables and when this
condition here holds
then
that variety is going to be an
equidimensional variety of the dimension
that one expects the amount of variables
minus the amount of polynomials and
degree this mixed volume where these are
the support of supports of the system
and this is the simplex repeated n minus
m times that would be the support of
the
linear
forms that one one is gonna be using to
for example obtain the degree
and we can use this to
give a probabilistic algorithm that
generalize an algorithm for
from geronimo materia solenoid and
winespan from 2009
uh that that that algorithm
is for square systems in this case
for
uh
as
for for a system with at most as many
polynomials as variables
we can
compute the geometric resolution of the
variety that are just defined
with a complexity that disregarding
logarithmic factors is polynomial
in
those combinatorial invariants there the
amount of variables the amount of points
in the supports the degree of the
variety
this other
mixed volume here and a combinatorial
invariant that depends on
a
fine mix subdivision that we include in
the input there are several algorithms
that compute this kind of subdivision
such as the one from mizutani takeda and
kohima from 2007
but they they work really efficiently in
practice but but they don't have an
explicit computation of their complexity
and that's why we don't include them in
the estimation
what is that number
this number
actually is going to be the maximum
of
the norms of the
primitive interior normal
of all the mixed cells
yes and actually this other mixed volume
comes from that subdivision but
exactly yes
and the basic idea is to take the
variety cut it with
n minus m generic linear forms
we then obtain a
finite points that we
find a geometric resolution of those
points using the algorithm from geronimo
material solenoid wine spain that i was
saying before and then we lift those
points to obtain the geometric
resolution of this variety
using a newton's enhancer lifting
we precision the degree of the variety
so now that we have this algorithm the
idea is to be able to reduce
the compute a description of every
component of the variety to that
algorithm that i was just talking about
for that i'm gonna need some notation
this projection you can forget that
after this slide but
the rest i'm gonna are gonna be
appearing a lot
so f i is going to be the system
that we obtain by evaluating in zero the
coordinates index by i and disregard
discarding the polynomials that vanish
completely j i is the set of index of
the polynomials that did not vanish
p is the projection to the coordinates
not in i and
the last one
is the set of supports of the system
that can also be obtained by projecting
with pi the polynomial the supports of
the original
original system
that are indexed by
i
so
if we have the first result is that if
we have an irreducible component of the
variety defined by f
and we define
this
set i
iw as the set of all
coordinates where all the points in w
have seo coordinates then the dimension
of w can be written in
using that iw and projecting the points
projecting w
with p sub i w is not only a set of
zeros of the syst of this system but
it's an irreducible component of this
variety that has at least one point with
all non-zero coordinates
using this
and using the first lemma
that
uh
that allow us to say that
f i is gonna have at least one zero with
all non-zero coordinates
if and only if we have that first
condition that blue condition on the
supports
um
and
using
that
for every reducible component of the
saris closure of all serials with
with all nonzero coordinates of f i
and adding zeros in the coordinates
index by i then that is an irreducible
component of the variety defined by f if
and only if we have this second blue
condition on the supports
those two blue conditions are only
combinatorial they are only on the
supports so they allow us to give a
combinatorial description of the variety
description that is gonna be there is
gonna be the union of our all eyes that
fulfill these two blue conditions
of adding zeros to this kind of
varieties that we know how to compute
from the previous algorithm
and also a combinatorial expression for
the degree as a sum over the same set i
that fulfills those two blue conditions
of the degrees of these varieties here
so using this
if we have a system
in sparse representation with a fixed
set of supports
first we find the second blue condition
and this other condition here that is
weaker than the first one but it's
easier to to
find
and it's also necessary
then
for every one of the sets i that feel as
to those conditions we found the
geometric resolution of the
of this variety and in doing
that we use that the pre-processing that
i was mentioning before
that in particular allow us to define
decide if this condition that i was
mentioning before the the first one is
going to be true or not because that
first condition is equivalent to the
mixed volume
of the set of supports of this variety
here this system here completed with
simplices
being 0 or not being 0.
so
adding 0 to the coordinates to the
corresponding coordinate and grouping by
dimensions
we have a geometric resolution that
describes each of the key dimensional
components of the variety defined by f
and this algorithm
is a probabilistic algorithm because of
this step here
and it's gonna have a complexity
that
this term is written in
combinatorial invariants similar as the
ones from before but the first one
unfortunately is exponential and cannot
be disregarded because we can have an
exponential amount of
irreducible components for example so
what's new here is the n 2 to the n
and to the end yes
and as i was saying for if we look at
this example if for every two variables
i choose one to make zero one to make
zero and so on
then there's two two different ways to
do that and that gives us two to the n
components that they are not included in
components of bigger dimension
so actually we can have as i was saying
an exponential amount of
components the good news is that for
systems such as this one where all the
supports are the same
we could present um
these kind of systems are called
um
unmixed
and we could present
a new
reformulation of our characterization
think that
the if this is the
dimensional component of the variety
defined by f
then
uh where you are going to be able to
write it as the union over all isa to
fill these conditions here of these
linear spaces and for these kind of
conditions we did get an algorithm to
compute them in a
polynomial time
so that gives us an algorithm to compute
this kind of decomposition in a
polynomial time
so it's polynomial because you know you
don't have to look at
because all the all the a's are the same
you just look at one of them is that is
that it
um
not because
it's kind of like technical but
it was because we could in in each step
we could
like limit the amount of
uh
we were adding like one polynomial at
the time and in each step we had
a bound for the amount of
components that could appear in it was
the degree and so and they were
the
in each step we summed
these things so and at the end it was n
times the degree
and something else
so
for the non-generical case
um something
that is worth mentioning is that unlike
what happened with isolated roots where
the
in the generic for a generic system with
fixed supports the amount of isolated
roots is a superior bound
for the amounts of roots for an
arbitrary system with the same amount of
with the same supports it's not that
does not happen with the degree the
degree of an arbitrary variety with
fixed supports can be larger than the
degree of a generic system with the same
set of supports
so we need a bound for the degree
in 2001
teresa
pardo and sombra presented this bound
here for m polynomials in n variables
and just
more recently for the case of
the square case when we have n
polynomials in n variables
we could
improve a little that bound because it
does this one this new one it does it
does not involve a union of the supports
but
it's only four square systems
and this bound is important to us
because it's going to appear in the
complexity of the algorithms
the idea
we heard this morning about witness set
from
the the idea from some saying one player
about
using a witness set of weakness points
to represent the irreducible or and the
dimensional components of varieties
for the non-generic case the best that
we could do was to find geometric
resolution of what is called a witness
points superset this is a set of finish
points that contains a witness a set of
weakness points but also can contain
some points
in
components of bigger dimension
the basic idea is that
if we have if we add
generic linear forms to our system
then
it is known
that
uh
every time i say it is known i i think
that i'm reading too much game of
thrones
okay it is known that um
if we
if we take generic linear combinations
and generic linear combinations of these
polynomials and in particular if we take
this kind of generic linear combinations
where only the generic coefficients that
we're going to be using are these ones
then
the
all the isolated zeros of this system i
also i just isolated serious series of
this system here
so using that
having a system in sparse representation
with fixed supports and the mixed cells
in a fine mix subdivision of the
extended supports now not only the
supports
in the fur at first we find the
geometric resolution of the series of a
system
with this extended supports a genetic
system with this with these supports
then we choose generic linear forms and
use them to construct these systems here
and from the zeros from the original
system j
we use a homotopic deformation to find a
geometric resolution of a finite
infinite set of points that contain all
isolated series of this system
and clearing that from all the points
that are not in the variety defined by f
we obtain a family of geometric
resolutions
that are geometric resolution of finite
set of points containing witness points
of
witness set of points of
every dimensional component of the
variety defined by f
and
this algorithm is also probabilistic and
has a complexity that is polynomial in
the amount of variables the amount of
points in the extended supports
the degree of the maximum degree of the
polynomials that hadn't appeared before
and in particular in the
degree in the bound for the degree of
the variety that i was presenting before
and that is all thank you very much
are there any questions i'm just
wondering uh if
like what's the range that you can
practically compute like if i give you a
system of 48 variables and 48 equations
did you
solve it with
36 or something um
well um the good thing about this kind
of algorithms is that
they are
the complexity is in regards to the
mixed volume so if the mixed volume is
small if you have for example supports
that are kind of like i don't know
something like this
then maybe your degree will be really
big but the mixed volume is gonna be
really small so the complexity is gonna
be small
but the bad news is that i'm learning to
program right now i haven't learned
completely learned yet so i haven't been
able to
write my algorithms in a computer so i
don't know
which
how much time do they take
i can give you a theoretical description
of the complexity
it's two different tasks to devise an
algorithm and then to implement it
if you ever try to work on both
you like the fact that the the counter
twice
maybe yes please
another question
you are always taking the union of the
ais with delta
the unit simplex
for the
inaudible you are looking for roots in
cn
and not c star n
no that has a that was look at the
polynomials
yes because we are using these
polynomials here so the support of these
polynomials is the support of every
polynomial and a simplex
so so you don't gain you will not gain
a better complexity by looking
for
roots with non-zero coordinates
and maybe using a fine
any other questions
oh i'm sorry yes please
so
with respect to this algorithm
i can't hear you sorry
what is the difference between
the algorithm on this slide and the one
by uh gregoire
grimo salvia and marius for computing
geometric resolutions in
this one is more intrinsic i mean i
think this this one takes into account
polyjokes isn't that the difference
i think so yes
i think so what about the i mean the uh
the did you still sell salvia
the complexity will be depending on the
number of solutions which is which you
can borrow like that as well as the
degree of intermediate varieties which
we could probably hope to bound like
that
so wouldn't you be able to get the same
kind of results at the end with their
other one
i'm gonna have to think maybe like
maybe
we can talk about it later and
are there any other questions
okay what's that given
i